good evening I'm Denise Valdez a new
bill proposing that a lot of Nevada
legislature could change our state's
rental landscape assembly Bill 340 would
make evictions different and also
require landlords to go through a
specific Court filing process Sasha
Loftus joins us live at the Las Vegas
Justice Center downtown with more on
both sides of this issue
Denise of ab340 moves forward it would
require landlords to come here to the
courts before they evict someone now
those backing the bill say it would
level the playing field but those
opposing it say it could cause financial
problems
it's frustrating this man who doesn't
want to share his name says he's
struggling to make ends meet I look at
some of the people right down in my
neighborhood that had apartments right
there and just leave it on the street he
tells me rent at his apartment where
he's lived for nearly 30 years recently
jumped from 500 to 800 a month while his
landlord gave him a 60-day notice he's
come close to being evicted we often
hear the term summary eviction assembly
Bill 340 presented to the Nevada
legislature assembly Judiciary Committee
Wednesday is meant to help people like
this like oh you've been evicted will
pregnant is with battleborn progress a
local organization backing the bill he
says it would require a landlord to file
an official court complaint and serve a
tenant with a copy of it before an
eviction if the landlord needs to evict
a tenant that can still happen but it
has to be their ability for the tenant
to reasonably respond to it but some
call ab340 a bad idea yeah Derek
mullinger a vice Realty Group which
manages this man's building sent a
statement saying in part landlords have
been destroyed in the state because of
ab 486 now the state seeks to further
damage landlords with this new bill what
I'm paying for he's not worth it at all
all while this one of many who says he
hopes to see something change
now AB 40 486 which passed around the
time of the pandemic stops eviction if
there is a pending application for
rental assistance that's set to expire
in June now as for this new bill it
still would have to pass through the
Senate and the State Assembly to get to
the governor's desk to be signed into
law as for the landlord that statement
we mentioned you can read that full
statement on our website 8newsnow.com
reporting live tonight social office 8
News Now